okay chef wonderful here we're starting
the crepes Nambe the amazing flambe now
look if you have to every bite him this
is not an easy dish but if you really
want to get into the most incredible
dessert on earth everything has to be
fresh I like to say brush it's a look
you can't use canned peaches that's the
easy trick people go buy canned peaches
and they just take them already sliced
and they put it in the palm bay if you
do that you'll burn in hell an eternity
you've got to go through the whole
process of finding slightly over ripe
peaches like I have here and then you're
gonna blanch them you're gonna put them
in boiling water to remove the skin in
the most efficient matter all right look
it takes time but nothing good happens
unless you're willing to work at it all
right that's what I'm talking about here
here is the peach wooden spoon it's the
right way to do it that way you don't
burn yourself as heat goes up the metal
into the boiling water it goes it
confuses the peach that's what happens
and it lets that it's skin know that
it's got to separate from the flesh or
the meat of the peach and we're gonna
need these peaches why because we want
that beautiful delicate slightly
overripe peach inside the crepe flambe
that's the key to success each one at a
time it takes a tremendous amount of
time it's work cooking is not easy my
friends but the end game is to make the
very best and every time I make it I get
better and better leaving the
competition in the dust all right we're
taking the peach out all right here's a
little trick come over to the sink pour
a little cold water on it to shock the
peach back to room temperature see that
a lot of people don't know this now
most great chefs bond with a knife this
is my knife this was made by a master a
folded steel whose family started as a
summer I
like he actually made summarize swords
think about that you can see the folds
right here see that this blade has never
been touched by any other hand except
chef wonderful I am one with the blade
we have a relationship we understand
each other that's what matters
[Music]
now our trick is to use the blade that
your one with my blade summer.i sword
from the 1800s
so sharp it would slice your finger off
and you didn't respect it but I also
communicate with it and I'm going to
twist it in half here and get the fruit
in half that sides ready then I dig in
and remove the stone and now the fruit
is one with me and I use the blade to
slice it thinly because I know I'm going
to the clip for Lumbee and I want it to
be very very thin just gorgeous oh my
goodness it's perfect but you know I try
every single fruit I don't let a single
sliver of peach ever go into one of my
crypt long base unless I have tasted it
first but that's that first isn't that
beautiful look at the color of that
fruit it's absolutely gorgeous here's
the other side oh my goodness I can
smell it right now it is a beautiful
peach unbelievable and just to prove it
I'll take one slice ready always embrace
the fruit put it on the palate oh the
delicacy of that fruit is different than
the last peach it has more of a texture
to it which is gonna be perfect for the
flambe will you make it
[Music]
gather your fruit put it into a bowl
because you're gonna be doing something
with this you're gonna be reducing it
with the sauce later this is where you
actually get the juices out into a syrup
and we're watching our watch oh my
goodness is that an AP jumbo with a red
band yes it is the best watch to cook
with absolutely gorgeous remember when
you're cooking you have to keep your
style it'll take me a while so when I
come back I love all the fruit ready and
then we'll go to the stage of making the
Cape itself that is an art it's half art
half science many people don't
understand this isn't about a recipe
it's about a feel it's about a tone it's
about an understanding between you and
the flour and the milk and the egg all
coming together embracing each other and
zoning in together to make the perfect
paper-thin Craig that's next on the hit
parade I'll see you in a couple of
minutes
[Music]
like don't feel that while it's dirty
like wait till it's cleaned off and then
filming your shop dirty when it looks
there's like a lot of dirt coming off
there yeah this is working coming this
is super heavy yeah yeah oh my god if
he's a bad influence you know so nasty
yeah
shuffle knows the ways of the blonde
shape oh you should hear yourself it's
almost too much okay so now we have to
make the reduction this is where we
actually blend my secret we have our
peaches ready
we blonde shade then we took the skin
off we sliced them very finely there
they are
but we have to make the part of our
reduction which is gonna be the jelly or
the paste or the internals aspect of the
Captain alum bait so what do we need
here's the secret sauce we're gonna take
out we're gonna get my blade of desire
oh my goodness my trusty friend from
years and years and what we're gonna do
is we're gonna cut some oranges and get
remember I said fresh everything's fresh
I don't want anything that isn't fresh
you burn in hell for that so I'm taking
fresh oranges I'm gonna squeeze them
well those squeeze are here I'm gonna
get 1 cup of fresh juice of that orange
all right here we go
cutting the orange in half the blade of
desire
[Music]
where are they oranges so look the big
challenge in CREP flambe is to make the
reduction that reduction that's actually
going to be inside the crepe itself now
I have a little secret to this what I do
is I blend a little orange with the
peach the reduction so what I'm gonna
have to do we've got all our beautiful
peaches we blanched slice them thinly
they still have texture now we get some
fresh add-ons some oranges okay but
remember what I said I don't want any
fake stuff it's got to be fresh 100%
fresh so what I'm doing is I'm taking a
fresh orange cutting it in half right
don't have to worry about the pips
because I've got a great little juicer
here I'm going to take one cup of fresh
orange juice that's what matters here
[Music]
yeah baby oh I can smell the juice
tattoes and a little bit the oils coming
through that's what makes the experience
so incredible look at let's just listen
isn't that a beautiful sound oh my
goodness fresh orange juice like that is
nectar here a little bit more look at
how beautiful that is
sweets maybe we only need three that all
wants to do this but fresh fresh fresh
fresh fresh I don't want any frozen
orange juice I want nothing and anything
mr. wonderful does or chef wonderful
that is not real and this is totally
real look at that reduction more fresh
orange juice perfect as we're talking
about air the stream of beauty I love
the sound of that oh my goodness the cup
we have all of our beautiful blanched
peaches we have a big pan now here's the
secret we got to be very careful with
this I'm gonna be adding a little butter
a little evil there I know this calories
but the taste is magnificent and then a
little brown sugar that's the secret but
not too much not too much so put all
that together and then we'll let it
reduce that vadik soon that's the dream
and we'll do it slowly with a wooden
spoon will embrace these wonderful fresh
flavors and when we get it to something
that's almost jam like in nature jam
esque then it's ready to be put inside
the crepes but first we have to make the
crepes this is a lot of work but
somebody's got to do it wait wait wait
here's the key to success if you're a
chef and that's what I'm doing today
chef wonderful the best prep bombe in
the whole world
Ichi okay aren't you guys at least
interested in trying these cooking creme
flam flambe
I have a little bit of brown sugar we're
gonna be using that and some fresh
unsalted butter unsalted butter okay
this is key you can add your salt later
if you wish
I don't want salt in this dish right now
because
making the reduction this is almost the
jam that's going to go inside that cadet
flambe and we've got to do it just so
we're combining the peach flavors and
the texture of the fruit of peach with
the Jews dad owns putting them together
so let's start first we take a big flat
pan heat it up right here I'm gonna
start with just a little bit of butter
we got our blade of desire out remember
this blades from the 1800s
a little bit of butter not too much you
don't have to over butter anything I
always tell people you want to give the
hint of butter but you don't want to
overdo it I have I'm going to share some
secrets with you about how this
reduction happens but this is the key to
making the connector now mate if the
reduction is weak if it's too thin it's
a disaster if it's too thick it changes
the text of the dessert and it's also
disaster and then I just throw it this
little secret and we're having a little
O'Leary Moscato one of the greatest
fantastic perfect sweet wines for a dish
like this but we're not letting the
butter burn it's so little secrets just
a little spinach you put that in there
oh yeah there you go now
you introduce a little bit of the fresh
juice and dad always remember fresh or
juice has lots of sucrose in it it's got
sugar look at that not too much that's
just about enough and then of course
what we want to do is reduce our heat a
bit because we got the butter going I'm
gonna cut that down just sort of a
simmer a bit of an art here just
understanding the relationship between
the juice that owns the butter a little
bit of that Moscato
[Music]
just don't call the splash ah now we
want to get this going so what's
happening here is we're starting to
reduce the orange to is taking out the
water as it comes to a simmer and then
the sucrose remains and it starts to
thicken just about now we want to
introduce our peaches are banal Shea
peaches that we did all that work on to
take the skin off and get the perfect
fresh fruit slightly over ripened oh you
can just smell that beautiful citrus
orange smell it's just spectacular
I just love that I just love it when
that happens now here's a little secret
again I don't introduce too much but I'm
throwing in a little bit of brown sugar
just a tease a little teenage tease and
I'm saying just a little bit to make
that a little sweeter but not too much I
don't like to over sugar anything now
remember our beautiful peaches all my
goodness they're flowing with desire
right now we did such a spectacular job
in that we're gonna take a whole bunch
of them and slide them into the Ducks
young right now
Oh laughs spectacular now remember this
is going to give the fiber this is going
to give the intensity to what we're
building up for the center of the
correct Pelham Bay this really matters
oh yeah
look at that look at that la la you know
I always clean up in the kitchen I hate
a dirty kitchen wipe that down just like
that oh my goodness while we're waiting
for the reduction I want to show you
something about the tools of making
crepe itself this is a real art this is
hundreds of years old this is a crepe
pan very low and shallow
we're gonna show you how we'd make the
crepe also something you want to do just
with a combination of flour egg and milk
but then you need the rake you have to
go around the edge of the pan like this
to flatten it out so it becomes perfect
this is very hard to do
I learned this years ago as an
apprentice in the kitchen but it's
absolutely spectacular do it right
because it comes out just perfect
[Music]
back now is the hardest part
making the crepe itself now the making
of a crepe is really art because there's
so many debates about how to do it
forget recipes you have to feel the
crepe you have to bond with the actual
elixir deciding how thick it should be
it's made of three basic components okay
egg this white flour milk I'm using 1%
milk because I'm trying to keep my felt
Adonis body in shape
I don't want extra fat when they don't
need it and this as we're now blending
oh my goodness the reduction is looking
so great here's another little secret
about the reduction just well we're just
getting on there you know what this is
it's Grand Marnier made from oranges the
orange reduction itself ooh la la
wow that is the secret sauce Oh
anyways that's fantastic but there's no
dessert without the creme
so we got to put some eggs together I'm
going to basically start with four eggs
that's what we're gonna put in here and
you know there's no recipe to this you
can't write this down you have to kind
of go and learn I learned this from my
mother she taught me how to make crepes
and then my father was really into it as
well and we debated for hours what's the
perfect blend of the some people but
sugar in here I think that's a faux pas
I think that's unnecessary given how
much sucrose and sugar is going into the
reduction see this white flour many
people think white flour is evil but for
a crepe you got to have it and putting
it in I don't know how much yet I'm just
feeling oneness with the eggs and then
in Abu Dharr they that's the 1% milk I
have a vibe I have a feeling for this
first blame okay so I'm whisking I'm
blending together the milk with the
flour and the eggs ooh la la
there we go well at last see that you
want a big base pan you want to bring
air you want to introduce it and you're
gonna get all the little pieces of flour
bunching but you're gonna have to
your way through that this is the real
art of whisking you see how I'm using it
to lift it right out of the bowl and
then I'm getting all the little pieces
of flour this is the whiskery no effect
yeah baby
it's like making an omelet in some ways
but I'm looking at it and sink to myself
in my years of experience as chef
wonderful that is not what I want yet
I want more white flour and in food
delay a little bit of the 1% milk
because I want something else that I
don't see yet I want something more
consistent with a sort of a thicker oh
there we go you see I'm starting to feel
it I'm starting to get one this is why
I'm saying there's no recipe there's
only you the whisk the eggs the bowl the
flour the milk and you are blending and
combining and communicating with what
you've got in the bowl and you're
deciding am i there yet
am i there oh oh while we're here look
at the reduction you see a great chef
has to keep an eye on everything on the
stove oh the reduction is looking
spectacular Oh laughs oh and then just
the aroma is just killing me you know
it's just reminding me how great this
desserts gonna be that little drama and
yeah I threw in there you can't do that
into the crepe itself now some people at
this point introduce a little salt I'm
against that many people don't want that
salt flavor but it has been done by many
chefs but I'm starting to see what I'm
looking for I'm starting to see a
consistency I like and I'm liking that
now how to prepare the pan our reduction
is looking fantastic it's coming
together we're letting it happen the
heat looks perfect
I might crank it up just a tad just to
confuse the elements just a little bit
now there's a big secret to making crepe
you're gonna use a pan like this very
heavy and you have to heat it up to just
the right temperature not too hot not
too cold you'll know when you put the
crepe on you'll do a little test
we're gonna show you how to do that you
do a spanking of CREP on there just to
see what happens if it's hot enough but
what I like to do is actually use a
paper towel to embrace the pan with a
little bit of oil so I get separation
from the batter and the surface first we
got to heat it up all right
I'm gonna start it up hot would allow
that's hot Louella all right now we need
a paper towel we're going to be using
the canola oil another gift from my
mother who taught me how to do this all
right
now what we want to do is embrace the
canola we don't to burn the oil we just
want up a little bit on it and then we
use the paper towel to actually cover
the surface this is a trick she taught
me because you get real consistency
others try to do it with spatulas and
stuff but the paper towel is perfect so
I'm using the ladle I'm taking a good
dose and I putting it down on the pan
knowing I can spread it out with the
rate that's the art remember the rake
you've got to get this right you want to
push it out to the edges I want to learn
how to do this it's not easy but they'll
they'll try and teach you this see what
I've done here it's enough to make a
full crepe I'm not embarrassed by that
and then the great thing about crepes is
you can fill in a little bit you cheat
if you thought you had a little bit of
reduction on the edges no problem and
you'll use your rake to fill in the
holes this is what they don't teach you
in school but chef wonderful showing you
your feeling in your crepe you're making
it perfect there we go
oh sable sable I have one little hole
here I'm just showing the truth I'll
just fill that little hole in with a
little dab because I'm chef wonderful
I'm getting away with murder perfect
look
crepe that is absolutely Gort for verbal
rubber hits the road you take a crepe
alright you put it down you get your
reduction which you've been working into
a jammy consistency it's hot it's gonna
burn your fingers but it's beautiful all
right this is where you've got the
consistency of the peach married to the
Xu's that Onge you brought in all your
different consistencies to it a little
bit as I said of that brown sugar gras
Marnier the reduction of orange this is
the essence of the crab flambe you don't
want too much but you don't want too
little you want to make it a beautiful
experience as a dessert in the middle
you go then
the roll a this is where you put it
together you fold in the two edges okay
then you take the center put it over top
this has been done for centuries you put
this flap on top taking our beautiful
reduction getting just the right texture
[Music]
so beautiful the smell of this is so
gorgeous look at that jammy consistency
but you still see the assaults of the
peaches they're still there the textures
there the reduction of the orange juice
is perfect now you can introduce the
flambe the fire of desire I'm choosing
Grand Marnier because it's got orange in
it which complements what we were doing
at the peach in the orange you have to
be liberal
you're soaking it in a bath because I'm
a traditionalist I go with a match
are you ready seal it with a kiss the
flame the desire the passion the flambe
itself laid it in several places there
it goes you can see the blue flame be
careful because you don't see it but
it's burning hot
oh it's flambe right now oh la la ooh la
la spectacular look at see the blue see
the blue that is the essence of
combining all the elements this is the
flambe moment it's heating it up
bringing you back to dessert temperature
embracing the different elements to this
oh look at that you don't want to burn
the crepe you can use a towel but that
little carbon action is okay too
that's fine there we go see what's
happening there it's caramelizing it's
fighting back oh look
fire fire fire that gives you an idea of
what's going on with the flambe oh look
who's here
I'm making your favorite honey CREP
flambe of course it's very good it's
taking me four hours to do this you're
gonna have one
all right let's go to the table all
right let's go
[Music]
alright let's try it let's find out how
great is this everybody take their first
bite I've been working on this for four
hours now oh my goodness you know and
want just the consistency of the
reduction a little bit of the whipped
cream the best I've ever made it's never
been better is that not spectacular come
on kiddies that is the best ever oh wow
oh that is amazing oh my goodness that
is crazy
so the crepe are perfect the reduction
was perfect the whipped cream is
gorgeous
hmm the S sauce combining the peach with
the orange the reduction the Grand
Marnier that little tad of brown sugar
all together they're caramelizing with
the flambé at the end reach this
masterpiece I'm speechless
I have nothing more to say this is
perfection perfection now you tried at
home
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you